OLI PALL GEIRSSON: Iceland can
be harsh like a lunar landscape.
But it can also be vivid and green.
And I have these moments when I'm biking to
work and it's dark. And I can see the stars,
and I can see the moon. A harsh winter and a
long night can also be beautiful. And when the
summer finally arrives, it brings out the
joy. And it really, really reconnect to
people who live here again, a really close-knitted
community. And being a part of that matters to me.
CREW:
Sir, can you just introduce yourself?
- Yes. My name is Oli Pall
Geirsson. And I serve as the
chief data officer at the City of Reykjavik.
OLI PALL GEIRSSON:
The data scientist finds the story in the data.
When I started here, I felt like it was a clean
slate. Our mission was to build something. We know
that digital transformation is ahead. We need to
evolve with society. How can we, as
a city, use data and data analytics
to help people, to have them accessible on the
web, to put down these barriers, these walls,
to improve the quality of life
for the residents of Reykjavik?
Your work means something to somebody.
Our role here as data science office is to
bring value from data to our stakeholders
within the City of Reykjavik. The stakeholders
could be the Department of School and Leisure.
It could be the Department of Welfare, Urban
Planning, or City Council, or the residents.
- It's almost like going through the phone
book or something like that. But you have to
go there, talk to them, listen. And
do it again, and again, and again.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: We are just right outside the
Arctic Circle, so during the winter, it gets dark.
And it's obviously cold in Iceland.
So the first thing you kind of
get to know about Icelanders is that they
are crazy about their swimming pools.
[SPLASHING]
- It's ingrained in our culture.
When you have family photos,
you maybe go to the countryside and take
photos. But my brother, for instance,
got a photographer to meet them up at the swimming
pool, because that's where they were every day,
essentially. So his family photos, you
know, they're standing by the swimming pool.
- I got a frequent request, even phone calls,
on why can't I see how many guests are in the
swimming pools right now. I need to know this. And
also like why can't I just predict how many people
are going to be in the pools for next hour or so,
two hours or more, in different swimming pools.
And what we would like to do is to show the
percentage, the capacity of the swimming pool.
Like Laugardalslaug, which is one of the cool
swimming pools here, is at 50% right now. And
we predict it's going to be at 70% in an hour and
35% in two hours. So we started looking into this,
and this became a project on our side
with the Department of Sports and Leisure.
But when we started to dive into it, we saw
that, hey, this is going to be a bit complicated.
- I should be looking at you and not the camera.
CREW: Yeah.
- OK.
- Should I start now?
CREW: Yes.
- I'm talking to you. OK.
CREW: Who the heck are you?
- If I knew-- no, I'm kidding. My
name is Inga Ros Gunnarsdottir.
- My name is Hlynur Hallgrimsson.
- My name is Sigridur Erla.
- My name is Thorbjorn Thorarinsson.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: I'm a senior data scientist.
SIGRIDUR ERLA FRIDGEIRSDOTTIR:
I am a data scientist.
THORBJORN THORARINSSON: Data scientist.
INGA ROS GUNNARSDOTTIR: A project
manager for Reykjavik City
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: Reykjavik.
SIGRIDUR ERLA FRIDGEIRSDOTTIR: Reykjavik City.
THORBJORN THORARINSSON: The City of Reykjavik.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: My role is
modeling, advanced analytics, and
predictive modeling. That's me, I guess.
THORBJORN THORARINSSON: Finding meaning or value,
and something that looks like chaos at first,
and finding a meaningful and
beautiful way to present it.
INGA ROS GUNNARSDOTTIR: To put a structure
on the data team's work, how to break it
down and help them keep their deadlines,
or nothing ever happens too quickly for me.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: We have
different backgrounds and
different skill sets within the team.
Thorb is an amazing machine learning guru,
but he is also-- like he has this eye for
detail. There's something of an artist about him.
- Hlynur, he is a great programmer.
CREW: And what happens when your
team ignores your deadlines?
- They never do.
-
We have these gates, and it counts how
many guests are arriving into the pool.
- We can say, OK, this is just a cumulative
sum of people that have gone swimming today.
- That's a bit of a pickle because we
really don't want to know how many people
have been counted in. Hey, there are 10,000
people on the pool. That makes no sense.
Can we fix that without buying new gates
or changing the protocol? Turned out that--
- --we have historical data
for in and out of the gates
for one swimming pool in Iceland,
the largest swimming pool.
- It's because there you have these bracelets
that you need to hand in when you go out.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: So we contacted the
hardware provider and they provided us
with historical data.
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: And the data is corrected,
with respect to these bracelets, and afterward.
So we have the data on how long they're staying.
There is a distributional property
that we can extract out of it.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: But to make
things a little bit more complicated,
if there's a queue of people
trying to leave the swimming pool,
the people who work at the swimming pools are kind
enough to like, OK we'll just open the gates for
you. You don't have to use your card to leave. But
that's wonderful for everybody except for the data
people, because that ruins our data, essentially.
We look at it like it's the kindness of man
ruining our perfect structured data. So
we have to account for that discrepancy.
- Our model is a very simple one. It's a
linear plans model and the only inputs are--
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: --the time of the day,
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: --day of the week,
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: --and times a year.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: Every five minutes we
have a process and web methods that reads data
from the swimming pool gate and stores them in
our data link. We then use the pins packets.
We get pinned linear models from RStudio
Connect, and we then predict the duration,
then we pin that result staple in RStudio
Connect. And that's what our Shiny app accesses.
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: So before launching
it, it had to go through testing--
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: --to make sure
that this is grounded in reality.
- Because we are not swimming pool executives.
We don't really know these numbers.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: We set up a separate Shiny
app for the managers of the swimming pools.
- So going through the testing, it matters to
it to go fast, to deliver quickly, and in a way
that they understand. To show them the numbers,
show them the time series, and preferably life.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: So it's just like an
interactive GT plot. So you just hover over,
like this is the time now, it's half past 12:00.
The app says that there are 50 people here.
Let's do a count. The feedback was like it's
essentially, 10 minutes later, everything is
spot on. And we thought, OK is there something we
need to improve? And they said, no, this is fine
because that's maybe how long it takes for you
to walk there, or bike, or ride your car there.
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: When we
launched it, it was immediately
well-received by the residents of Reykjavik.
-
Like a lot of how we
are able to get things off the ground
quickly has to do with R and RStudio Connect.
THORBJORN THORARINSSON: So
when you do it often enough,
you have all the tools and you just
have to pick and choose what works best.
HLYNUR HALLGRIMSSON: We are the people
that actually work with the data,
but now we're also the people that can
deploy this, and schedule it, and put up
a Shiny app in production within a week.
- All the process of transforming and
building up this analytical tables of
products and publishing it, the data science team,
if it can do all of that inside one domain,
they become superheroes. They can do everything.
THORBJORN THORARINSSON:
I think I do what I do not only because I
love coding and making beautiful things, but
also because I believe that working
at the City of Reykjavik, I can
improve people's lives if only a small bit.
INGA ROS GUNNARSDOTTIR: Making a difference,
and maybe it's small, at least it's making
an impact which hopefully ends with the
citizens and making life better for them.
OLI PALL GEIRSSON: If you want to
make changes, if you want to matter,
then you need to embrace the fact it's going to be
challenging. You have to just know it's going to
be ride. That's something that I didn't quite
realize the magnitude of it before I started.
But that's a ride worth taking, because
through the experience, you grow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]